In this problem, a given area is being graded for a project.
How much additional film material in cubic yards will be required at or need to be removed
from this project site.
So when I see a problem like this, the words that come to mind for me are cut and fill.
Searching for either of those in the reference manual will bring us to the Earthwork Volumes
section of chapter 2, where we can find the average end area method described for
finding Earthwork, Cut, and Fill volumes.
The average end area method for Earthwork calculates volume between two consecutive cross
sections as the average of their areas multiplied by the distance between them, where
fill is positive and cut is negative.
The equation is given as follows.
The volume here equals the multiplication of the distance between two cross sections L,
and the sum of their end areas of cross section A1 and A2 divided by two.
So let's begin to solve this problem.
We have already been given our table of stations as well as the cut and fill volumes being
excavated or cut and fill areas being excavated at each station.
So plugging these into the equation, average end area method should give us what we need.
So first we're going to go from station 1 to station 2.
And then we're going to go from station 2 to station 3.50.
Next we can focus on our cut volumes first.
So in this case V equals our length between stations is 100 feet, and we have no cut volumes
in area 1 or area 2.
So this is going to simply be 0 cubic feet.
We do have a cut volume in area 2 of the measurement between station 2 and 3.5.
So the length here is 150 feet between the two stations.
And again area 1 for us, which is the old area 2, will be 0.
Area 2 for our current one is going to be 50.
And this will give us 37.50 feet cubed.
Next we can look at our fill volumes for both stations.
Again our total length between station 1 and 2 is 100 feet.
And this time we have fill values in both of these stations.
200 feet squared plus 75 feet squared over 2.
And that's going to give us 13, 750 feet cubed.
And our next measurement is going to be between station 2 and 3.5.
I keep saying that wrong, but between these two stations.
So that's going to be 150 feet.
This is going to be whoops not 50.
This is going to be 75 feet squared plus 0 feet squared over 2.
And that's going to give us 5, 6, 2, 5 feet cubed.
So now we've assembled our total cut volumes for each station.
And our total fill volumes for each station.
So our next step is to simply sum all of these together.
The formula notes that fill is positive and cut is negative.
So let's keep that convention here.
So we have plus 13, 750 feet cubed for the fill volume for station 1 to 2.
And plus 5, 6, 2, 5 feet cubed from station 2 to 3 plus 50.
And nothing in the fill volume, the cut volume for station 1 to 2.
And then negative 3, 750 feet cubed.
So fill, fill, cut, cut.
And that's going to come out to 15, 6, 2, 5 feet cubed of fill material.
And finally, since the equation is asking, or the question is asking for this to be in cubic yards.
We will convert that.
So 15, 6, 2, 5 feet cubed times 1 yard cubed over 3 feet cubed equals 578 yards cubed of fill material.
So as you can see here, it's going to require approximately 580 additional cubic yards of fill material in order to complete this project.
Logically, we can even see this in the image based on the fact that station 1 and station 2 both require more fill material than can possibly even be excavated at the third station.
So this whole problem pretty much only requires knowing where to find the average end area method equation and how to apply it, which is pretty simple.
And that's all it takes to solve this problem.